COMMITTEE ON ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AND INTERNET
MEDIA.
THIS CALL TO ORDER AND WE DON'T
HAVE A CORE AND YET.
WELL WE HAVE THE SENATORS
SKINNER READY TO PRESENT -- SB
[inaudible]
TWO ZERO SIX SO SENATOR
[inaudible] FOR SHORTS
-- YEAH
.
OKAY THANKS SO MUCH -- THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- WE ARE
PRESENTING.
I AM JOINED BY MY PRINCIPAL.
JOINT CO AUTHOR -- CENTER
BRADFORD AND WE ARE PRESENTING
SB TWO OH SIX SB TWO OH SIX
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING.
ISSUE IN COLLEGE ATHLETICS AND
THAT IS THAT OUR STUDENT
ATHLETES ARE TREATED FAR
DIFFERENTLY THAN ANY OTHER
CATEGORY OF STUDENTS THEY ARE
THE ONLY CATEGORY OF STUDENTS.
THAT ARE COMPLETELY PROHIBITED
FROM MONETIZING THEIR SKILL OR
TALENT IN ANY WAY IF YOU
CONSIDER ANY OTHER COLLEGE MAJOR
THERE IS NO RESTRICTION ON THAT
COLLEGE MAJOR WHETHER THAT
COLLEGE STUDENT IS AN
ENGINEERING STUDENT A COMPUTER
SCIENCE STUDENT MUSIC.
MAJORING IN MUSIC MAJORING IN
DRAMA THERE IS NO PROHIBITION ON
THERE USING THEIR SKILLS. TO TO
PERFORM TO RECORD TO PRODUCE AN
APP TO DO COMPUTER GRAPHICS.
ONLY COLLEGE ATHLETES SO WHAT IS
SB TWO OH SIX DO.
IT PROVIDES OUR COLLEGE ATHLETES
THE SAME RIGHTS AS OLYMPIC
ATHLETES TO RECEIVE A FINANCIAL
GAIN FROM THEIR NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS THROUGH SPONSORSHIPS
AND ENDORSEMENTS.
YESTERDAY ON THE FLOOR OF BOTH
OF OUR HOUSES FOR PRIDE MONTH WE
ARE HONORED A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AMONG THEM WAS FORMER NBA PLAYER
JASON COLLINS [inaudible]
NOW.
AFTER THE CEREMONY I WAS
SPEAKING WITH JASON COLLINS AND
HE HAD SEEN THE USA TODAY
ARTICLE SO WE TALKED ABOUT SB.
TWO OH SIX WHAT DID HE TELL ME
HE SAID THAT AS A STUDENT AT
STANFORD.
HE SAW HIMSELF DEPICTED IN A
VIDEO GAME ABOUT BASKETBALL.
THIS WAS A GAME THAT HE HAD
PURCHASED.
YET IT WAS USING HIS LIKENESS
WITHOUT PERMISSION OR WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY PAYMENT.
THESE ARE THE TYPES OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT COLLEGE
ATHLETES CONTINUALLY FACE.
NOW FOR FEMALE ATHLETES THE
PROBLEM IS EVEN MORE SERIOUS
BECAUSE AND I IMAGINE MANY OF
YOU ARE THINKING YOU KNOW THE
MALE ATHLETES THEY HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY TO GO PRO.
OF COURSE YOU'LL HEAR LATER WHAT
TINY TINY PERCENT OF ATHLETES
EVERY EVEN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
GO PRO BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WOMEN ATHLETES.
THERE ARE FEW TO NO PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES.
COLLEGE MAY BE THE ONLY TIME FOR
WHICH THEIR ATHLETIC PROWESS
MAYBE SO VALUED THAT THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR HOME TOWN
CAR DEALER FOR THAT MATTER
SPONSORED THEM OR ROTARY CLUB OR
QANTAS CLUB.
ALL OF WHICH IS PROHIBITED NOW
UNDER THE AND SEE TO A ROLES.
AND THOSE RULES CREATE AS I
MENTIONED VERY UNFAIR CONDITIONS
CONDITIONS THAT THE FORMER CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF THE NC TO A
DâN BOGAN WHO WAS ALSO A FORMER
VICE CHANCELLOR AT UC BERKELEY.
HE SAYS THEY ARE CONTRADICTORY
TO A KEY TENET OF THE NC TWO
EIGHT OWN BYLAWS.
AND IN WITHIN THE NC TWO WAYS BY
LAWS IS THE FOLLOWING PHRASE.
THAT THEIR RULES ASSURE THAT
ATHLETICS PARTICIPANTS ARE NOT
TREATED DIFFERENTLY FROM ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE STUDENT BODY.
AND YET AS I DESCRIBED THE
STUDENTS ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
THAN ANY OTHER [inaudible]
STUDENT MEMBER -- I'M GONNA TURN
NOW TO MY JOINT AUTHOR SO HE CAN
MAKE SOME COMMENTS THANK YOU
CENTERS SKINNER AND MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I IT WON'T BE
REDUNDANT BUT I THINK ARE.
SINNERS SKINNER MADE IT CLEAR
THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT'S NOT
REALLY CENTERED ON SPORTS CENTER
ON FAIRNESS AND IN MANY WAYS
IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE --
AGAIN THE MAJORITY OF THESE
ATHLETES -- ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN
OVER HALF OF ON YOUR FOOTBALL
AND BASKETBALL TEAMS ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN YOUNG MAN DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THE ONLY MAKE UP 3%.
OF THE STUDENT BODY ON MOST
CAMPUSES IN UNIVERSITIES THE
YOUNG MAN AS WELL AS WOMEN --
FILL ARENAS ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WERE.
A UNIVERSITIES MAKE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BECAUSE OF THEIR
ATHLETIC TALENT.
AND THE REAL CONTRARY HERE IS
THAT YOU HAVE CULTURES THAT COME
INTO THESE YOUNG FOLKS HOMES
COACHES WARM NOW MILLIONAIRES
COACHES WHO CAN NOW SIR ASSAD
SIGNED ENDORSEMENT DEALS AS WELL.
FOR THE JERSEY FOR THE SHOES
THAT THESE ATHLETES APPLY A PLAY
AT AND AGAIN THESE ATHLETES ARE
NOT ABLE TO BENEFIT NOT ONE DIME.
I WANT TO SEND YOU A STATE OR
AYE A ODD TO THE COLLEGE WITH A
BUNCH OF ATHLETE TO ONE ON THE
APPLY PROS SPORTS.
BUT MANY OF THEM BORROWED MONEY.
FROM ME WHILE IN COLLEGE BECAUSE
DESPITE BEING ON A SCHOLARSHIP
THEY COULD MAKE ENDS MEET.
AT AGAIN A SCHOLARSHIP FOR THE
MOST PART ONLY PAY FOR TUITION
AND ROOM AND BOARD ON A VERY
MINIMAL A SITUATION YET WE ALL
KNOW YOU NEED FAR MORE.
THAN THAT TO SURVIVE MANY OF
THESE ATHLETES DID NOT EVEN HAVE
CARS.
NOT TO GET TO AND FROM.
A CAMPUS ONCE A FOR THOSE WHO
LIVE OFF CAMPUS SO.
THIS IS THE ISSUE OF FAIRNESS --
IT'S NOT ABOUT -- REALLY.
ALL.
GETTING RICH AS A COLLEGE
ATHLETE AT SOME FOLKS WANNA MAKE
THIS OUT BUT THE REAL PHENOMENON
HERE IS THAT.
MOST.
ATHLETE TO PLAY BASKETBALL ARE
RECRUITED UNDER THE PREMISE THAT.
IT'LL BE ONE AND DONE.
THEY SIGNED FOR ONE YEAR.
JUST AS WE JUST SAW LAST WEEK
ZION WILLIAMSON.
THE NUMBER ONE PICK IN THE
NATION.
AND THEY ENTERED SCHOOL LIKE
THAT.
OUR YOUNG MAN WHO GREW UP IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WHO WENT ON TO PLAY.
FOR A UNIVERSITY OF PORTLAND
PLATE FOR THE KINGS FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS HIS FATHER WAS VERY
CLEAR HE'S DOING ONE AND DOT.
HE'S GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
HIS ATHLETIC ABILITIES JUST GET
ENOUGH EXPERIENCE ON THAT --
INTO A COLLEGE LEVEL DIVISION
ONE LEVEL AND HE'S GONNA GO
PEARL AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S DONE
AND THAT'S WHAT INCENTIVIZE IS
MOST OF THESE YOUNG.
ATHLETES NOT EVEN TO A MANAGER
AT EDUCATION SO I WHICH AS I
STATED -- ON OUR FLOOR THAT THIS
BILL DID MORE I WISH IT
GUARANTEED CONTINUING EDUCATION
FOR ANY ATHLETE WHO PLAYED FOR A
MAJOR UNIVERSITY UNTIL THEY
ACHIEVE A DEGREE IN IF THEY WANT
TO GO ON TO GET A GRADUATE
DEGREE.
THEY SHOULD BE AFFORDED THAT
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE AGAIN.
THE GENERATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND DON'T BENEFITS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS -- THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COME SPEAK ABOUT
SB TWO OH SIX AS A FORMER
STUDENT ATHLETE MYSELF -- AND A
RETIRED ATHLETE I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY -- MY NAME IS ERIN
CAFARO AND I AM A TWO TIME
OLYMPIC GOLD MEDALIST AND A
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA.
GOLDEN BERYL -- SO -- GO BEARS --
I'M HERE.
TO SUPPORT SB TWO OH SIX FOR THE
WELL BEING OF THE CURRENT STERN
ATHLETES AND ALSO BRING TO LIGHT
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE BILL.
FOR THE FUTURE SUCCESS OF
STUDENT ATHLETES AND THEIR
FUTURE ENDEAVORS AFTER
GRADUATION [inaudible]
SO.
I WALKED ONTO THE COW WOMEN'S
ROWING TEAM -- AS A FRESHMAN AND
WAS ABLE TO EARN A PARTIAL
SCHOLARSHIP.
BY MY SENIOR YEAR AND THAT WAS
IN A LARGE PART THANKS TO TITLE --
NINE I MANY OF THE OLYMPIC SPORT
ATHLETES I COMPUTED WITH AND MET
DURING MY ATHLETIC CAREER.
WERE ALSO ON PARTIAL. TO KNOW --
SCHOLARSHIPS AS WELL.
AND THESE ATHLETES WENT ON TO
REPRESENT THEIR COUNTRY IN THE
OLYMPICS DURING THEIR
UNDERGRADUATE CAREER.
AND SOME OF THEM HAD TO MAKE
THIS HARD DECISION -- WHETHER TO
FOREGO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE SMALL WINDOW
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT --
OR NO LONGER COMPETE FOR THEIR
UNIVERSITY OR OF FINISH THEIR
EDUCATION [inaudible]
SO AFTER.
GRADUATION -- I WAS INVITED TO
TRAIN WITH THE US ROWING
NATIONAL TEAM.
AND IT TOOK ME TWO YEARS TO EARN
A SPOT.
ON OLYMPIC.
AND SO THAT MEANT I WENT TWO
YEARS WITHOUT A STIPEND OR
HEALTH INSURANCE -- SO.
I THE COMPENSATION FOR MY NAME
AND LIKENESS DURING MY AND SEE A
BELAY -- CAREER WHICH WE
ACTUALLY ALSO ONE TWO AND THREE
BLADE CHAMPIONSHIPS -- IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A SIGNIFICANT HELP
DURING THAT TIME AS I WAS
BUILDING MY NEXT CAREER AS A I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY.
THAT AN AMATEUR PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES -- THERE ARE MANY OTHER
ATHLETES THAT DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THEIR
SPORT -- AFTER COLLEGE
GRADUATION GRADUATION.
BUT THEY ALSO COMMITTED THESE
LONG.
HARD HOURS HONING THEIR SKILLS
TO REPRESENT THEIR SCHOOL.
WHILE THEIR CLASSMATES WERE ABLE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF INTERNSHIPS
AND JOBS DURING THIS TIME.
AND I SEE THIS ACTUALLY QUITE
FREQUENTLY NOW IS AYE MENTORING
A LOT OF OTHER STUDENT ATHLETES
AND THEY'RE HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING JOBS BECAUSE THEIR
RESUMES AREN'T AS COMPETITIVE --
THEY DID NOT HAVE THE EMPLOYMENT
EXPERIENCE THAT THERE.
COHORTS -- AND THEIR CLASSMATES
DEAD BECAUSE THEY WERE DOING
THEIR FULL TIME JOB AS AN
ATHLETE -- SO I KNOW.
WE TYPICALLY THINK OF THESE HOW
HIGH PROFILE SPORTS AS THE
BENEFICIARIES OF COMPENSATION --
FOR THE NAME IN NIGHT AT NAME
AND LIKENESS BUT I JUST WANT TO
BRING ATTENTION TO ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION OF
ATHLETES THAT COULD BENEFIT.
FROM THE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
SUPPORT -- NOT ONLY TO MAINTAIN
YOU KNOW THE OPPORTUNITY COMPETE
FOR THEIR SCHOOL BUT ALSO TO
SUPPORT THEIR TRANSITION FOR
THEIR FUTURE CAREER ASPIRATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS LEONARD SIMON I AM A LAWYER
IN SAN DIEGO.
A LAW PROFESSOR.
IN SAN DIEGO AS WELL I'VE TAUGHT
SPORTS IN THE LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO FOR THE
LAST.
DOZEN YEARS AND ALSO TAUGHT AT
USC AND MY ALMA MATER DUKE
UNIVERSITY -- I'M HERE AS AN
INTERESTED CITIZEN I'M NOT A
LOBBYIST NO ONE ASKED ME TO COME
HOME AND NO ONE BUT ME HOPE THE
HOTEL ROOM OR AIRPLANE TICKET
I'M HERE.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN WHAT --
WHAT CENTER SKINNER AND
ASSEMBLYMAN BRADFORD HAVE
PROPOSED THAT I HAVE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS I'VE TAUGHT AMATEURISM --
AND NCAA REGULATION FOR THOSE
DOZEN YEARS AND AS TIME HAS
PASSED AND PEOPLE OF SU THE NCAA
MANY MANY TIMES.
IT IS COME TO ME THAT THE PROPER
COMPROMISE.
OF THE DISPUTE OVER PAY FOR PLAY
IS EXACTLY.
WHAT THIS BILL [inaudible]
IT'S THE BILL IS IS IS
APPROPRIATE -- FOR SEVERAL
REASONS ONE IS THAT IT'S FAIR
AND IT'S QUITE CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW WHICH IS
UNDERMINED.
BY THE NCAA CALIFORNIA LAW
RECOGNIZES INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
IT RECOGNIZES THE NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS AS A AS A RIGHT THAT
ALL OF US HAVE ALL OF US CAN
MONETIZE HER NAME'S IMAGES AND
LIKE IT'S AS IF THEY'RE WORTH
ANYTHING MINE ISN'T WORTH MUCH.
OTHERS ARE WORTH A WHOLE LOT
MORE.
BUT AN ATHLETE WHO WISHES TO GO
TO COLLEGE WHICH I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING WE TRY TO ENCOURAGE.
CANNOT MONETIZE -- CANNOT
MONETIZE HIS OR HER NAME IMAGE
AND LIKENESS AT RISK OF LOSING.
COLLEGE EDUCATION SO WERE WERE
UNDERMINING CALIFORNIA LAW
[inaudible]
THE CURRENT STATUS QUO
DISCOURAGES EDUCATION.
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
DO IT DISCOURAGES STUDENTS FROM
GOING SCHOOL.
DISCOURAGES THEM FROM STAYING.
AT SCHOOL BECAUSE MANY OF THE
BEST STUDENTS WITH THE BIGGEST
BIGGEST NAMES AND MANY OF THE
OTHER STUDENTS WITH THE JUST THE
ROLE PLAYERS AND THE NON REVENUE
SPORTS.
REPORT.
MANY OF THEM WERE JUST MIDDLE
CLASS GOING TO COLLEGE IS
EXPENSIVE.
AND AS HAS BEEN SAID.
EARLIER.
A SCHOLARSHIP DOESN'T PROVIDE
EVERYTHING THERE ON A CAMPUS
WHERE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE SPENDING
MONEY THERE ARE OTHER THINGS ONE
WOULD LIKE TO DO THERE ARE
TRAINING COSTS.
AND THEY HAVE NO ACCESS TO ANY
MONEY OTHER THAN EXACTLY WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDES THAT.
THIS IS A SUBSTANTIAL
DISINCENTIVE TO GO TO SCHOOL OR
TO STAY IN SCHOOL THE YOUNG LADY
PLAYING SOCCER NAMES A LIBYA
MOULTRIE.
SHE'S FOURTEEN SHE'S ALREADY
QUITE WELL KNOWN FOR HER SOCCER
SHOULD NEVER GO TO COLLEGE.
BECAUSE SHE HIRED AN AGENT.
AND SHE'S MONETIZING HER SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR THE TRAINING THAT SHE NEEDS
AS A AS A WOULD BE.
FUTURE PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE OR
TO FUTURE MEMBER OF THE U. S.
WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM SO IT
FOURTEEN SHE'S BEEN FORCED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN.
FOLLOWING HER DREAM AND HER
PHENOMENAL TALENT AT FOURTEEN OR
GOING TO COLLEGE AND SHE'S
PERMANENTLY INELIGIBLE.
THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN DO TO
BRING IT BACK I DON'T THINK BUT
THERE ARE A LOT MORE OUT THERE
LIKE LIKE HER.
MATTHEW BOWLING IS AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD IN TEXAS WHO IS THE
FASTEST U. S. HIGH SCHOOL
SPRINTER ANYBODY'S SEEN IN A
DECADE.
HE HAS TO DECIDE THIS SUMMER
WHETHER YOU WANT TO GO TO
UNIVERSITY GEORGIA WHICH IS
OFFERED HIM A SCHOLARSHIP.
OR HE WANTS TO TRAIN
PROFESSIONALLY AND GET READY FOR
THE TOKYO OLYMPICS.
THAT'S HIS CHOICE HE NEEDS THE
FUNDING FROM NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS FROM SOCIAL MEDIA FROM
SHOE CONTRACTS IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR THE COACHING WHICH MIGHT GET
HIM READY.
SO YOU CAN GET AN EDUCATION OR
YOU CAN FOLLOW HIS DREAM.
I MAKE A VERY PERSONAL TO ME
BECAUSE I'M NOT A CALIFORNIA
GOLDEN BEAR I'M TO DUKE BLUE
DEVIL.
AND IF YOU NOTICED YEAH SIGNED
WILLIAMSON WHEN PRO TRUE.
OTHERS WHEN PRO ONE GUY DIDN'T
ON THAT FANTASTIC FRESHMAN TEAM
TRADE JONES.
STATE IS GONNA BE A SOPHOMORE
NEXT YEAR PLAYING BASKETBALL
[inaudible]
WHY?
I CAN ONLY TELL YOU ONE FACT
THAT MIGHT BE SIGNIFICANT WHICH
IS THAT HIS BROTHER IS A
PROFESSIONAL BASKETBALL PLAYER
AND HIS FAMILY IS PROBABLY WHAT
YOU WOULD CALL UPPER MIDDLE
CLASS HE GOT TO CHOOSE.
HE CHOSE.
THE STATE GET A FURTHER
EDUCATION AND MAYBE MAKE HIS
GAME A LITTLE BETTER. EIGHTEEN
YEARS AGO DO CAT A POINT GUARD
SAME POSITION WILL AVERY.
MIKE SHE CHESKY A COACH YOU
PROBABLY HEARD OF RECOMMENDED HE
STAY FOR ONE OR TWO MORE YEARS
AND HE LEFT APOLOGIZED TO THE
COACH.
AND THE SYSTEM IN SAID.
MY MOTHER DOESN'T HAVE ANY FOOD
YOU CAN'T PAY THE RENT I CAN'T
BE HERE ANY LONGER I'M SIGNING A
CONTRACT.
THAT'S NOT A POSITION YOU WANT
TO PUT YOUNG PEOPLE IN CHOOSING
BETWEEN AN EDUCATION.
AND AND TAKING CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES ARE TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES SO THE RULE REALLY
DISCOURAGES EDUCATION AND FORCES
UNFORTUNATE DECISIONS.
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY SAID THIS IS
TOTALLY INCONSISTENT WITH HOW WE
TREAT.
ARTISTS MUSICIANS AND ACTORS ON
CAMPUS THEY CAN THEY CAN COMPETE
IN NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL
COMPETITIONS -- WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE MAKING ANY
MONEY ON THE SIDE -- I THINK IT
RAISES VERY SERIOUS AND I TRUST
PROBLEMS BECAUSE NO UNIVERSITY
COULD EVEN MAKE ITS OWN DECISION
ON THIS ASSEMBLY DECIDED TO
EXPERIMENT.
AND DO WHAT SENATOR SKINNER HAS
PROPOSED.
THEY WOULD BE IN TROUBLE THERE
BUT THE UNIVERSITIES ARE MAKING
THE DECISIONS THE NCAA IS.
FINALLY I WOULD SAY.
THE BILL IS VERY BALANCED.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
PAY SALARIES.
IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE TOMORROW IT'S
GOT A THREE YEAR WINDOW AND
THERE IS -- LOTS OF ROOM TO GET
THIS DONE LOTS OF TIME TO GET
THIS DONE AND LOTS OF TIME.
UP FOR EVERYONE TO ADJUST TO A
CALIFORNIA.
IN THIS CASE IT'S NOT THE ONLY
STATE LOOKING AT THIS COLORADO
IS LOOKING AT A WASHINGTON
LOOKING AT BUT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
DO AS IT DOES IN MANY.
AREAS AND SHOULD LEAVE SHOULD
GET OUT AHEAD.
I WOULD URGE ECONOMIC THROUGH
THE BILL IN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS OLIVIA SMILLA
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEIL SWEENEY THE US TWENTY VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE U. A. W. FIFTY
EIGHT TEN AND ALSO REPRESENTING
YOUR W. TWENTY FIVE OR THIRTY
THOUSAND TEACHING ASSISTANTS
REASON TUTORS PUTS DOCTORS
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
STRONG SUPPORTER VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE OUR FULL RIGHTS IN PLACE
RESIDENT NIGHT FOR MANY FOR
DECADES REALLY BY THE UNIVERSITY
UNTIL THEY'RE FULLY RESOLVED BY
CENTER SKINNER'S BILL IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB TWO ONE
THANKS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA HAWAII
AND DOUBLE ACP AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MAY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAME WHEN DEAN FROM
THE ALLIANCE FROM BOYS TO MEN OF
COLOR AT POLICY LINK PROUD CO
SPONSORS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OF ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME FORWARD. TO HAVE ENOUGH
SEAT [inaudible]
MORE.
CAN I IN A STUDIO WITH
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT.
TO VIEW THE SEATS TO THE
OPPOSITION
-- ALLOWS THREE
WITNESSES SO.
WHICH WILL PUT YOU ON A TO START
[inaudible]
THE GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
AB FEE AND I SERVE AS THE
ATHLETIC DIRECTOR AT LONG BEACH
STATE UNIVERSITY -- AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH ALL OF YOU TODAY.
I AM HERE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL AND BRIEFLY WANT TO SHARE
MY THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS THERE
ARE MANY POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BILL.
THE CO AUTHORS PAINT ONE
POSSIBLE SCENARIO.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO
ANOTHER POSSIBLE SCENARIO WHERE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE FOR
AND STATE CHAMPIONSHIPS GOES
AWAY.
LONG BEACH STATE JUST HAPPENS TO
BE THE HOME OF THE BACK TO BACK
DEFENDING NATIONAL CHAMPION
MEN'S VOLLEYBALL PROGRAM.
IF CALIFORNIA CREATES RULES THAT
DRASTICALLY CONTRAST CURRENT AND
STATE PRINCIPLES AND THE FABRIC
OF AMATEURISM THE BECOMES AN
INHERENT ISSUE OF TWO WORLDS
THAT CANNOT CO EXIST.
I FEAR THE DISTINCT POSSIBILITY
OF A SCENARIO WHERE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS COULD BE EXPELLED FOR
WILLFUL BREAKING OF NCAA RULES.
WHICH IS DIRECTLY LINKED TO WHAT
THE NCAA REFERS TO AS A LACK OF
INSTITUTIONAL CONTROL.
SHE CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS BE
EXPELLED THE VERY STUDENT
ATHLETES THE BILL IS INTENDED TO
ASSIST WOULD BE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED.
DUE TO POSSIBLE LOSS OF
SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES DUE TO
SHATTERING OF NCAA ATHLETICS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD ADD THE CONVERSATION
WE'RE HAVING TODAY IS AN
IMPORTANT.
ONE AND WE ARE ALL FOCUSED ON
ENHANCING THE STUDENT ATHLETE
EXPERIENCE.
HOWEVER MY PERSONAL OPINION IS
THIS IS THE WRONG MECHANISM. TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND ULTIMATELY
DOES MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
THE MOST IMPORTANT EVENTS THAT
WE HOST TEACHER AT LONG BEACH
STATE UNIVERSITY IS COMMENCEMENT.
AND I FEAR THAT MANY FIRST
GENERATIONS DO NATALIE IT'S
COULD LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY. FOR
THE MOST IMPORTANT AND WHAT I
DESCRIBE AS PRICELESS A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
THAT DEGREE CARRIES THEM FORWARD.
AND CAN HELP THEM ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS DREAMS OR ASPIRATIONS.
AND IT IS LIFE CHANGING.
IN CLOSING.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL AGAIN
FOR ALLOWING US TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
MORNING PANELIST.
MY NAME IS LATONYA SHEFFIELD AND
I AM COACH OF MEN AND WOMEN'S
TRACK AND FIELD AT LONG BEACH
STATE.
I OPPOSE IT LEGISLATION BECAUSE
IT.
IT ALIGNS WITH THE POTENTIAL --
TO BE HARSHLY LIMITING -- TO OUR
OUR STUDENT ATHLETES.
IT CAN LIMIT THEM IN MANY WAYS.
FIRST IN THE COMPETITIVE
OPPORTUNITIES.
EVEN BY SPORT.
AND CERTAINLY BY GENDER.
DEFINITELY BY GENDER.
I CHAIR THE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION COMMITTEE -- AT LONG
BEACH STATE AND OUR ATHLETIC
DEPARTMENT.
AND WHAT ARE COR.
MOTIVATION IS TO INCLUDE TO
WELCOME.
AND THIS BILL IMMEDIATELY
[inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY.
IT'S A DIVIDE.
IT DIVIDES BECAUSE IT'S MEN.
FOOTBALL IT'S MEN BASKETBALL
IT'S MEN BASEBALL THAT WILL
LITERALLY GET THE IMMEDIATE.
THE IMMEDIATE.
ADVANTAGE.
WHERE OUR MINOR SPORTS?
SUCH IS.
OUR STUDENTS AT THE STUDENT
ATHLETES THAT I COACH.
THERE MIGHT THAT TO MINORITY
SPORT IN TRACK AND FIELD.
I HEARD SOMEONE SAY TODAY THAT.
THE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WOULD -- BE COMPROMISED.
I SAY THAT THE RIGOR OF GOING
PRO.
AND ALL THE HOURS THAT IT TAKES.
THAT IS THE LIMITING FACTOR.
YOU HEAR ALL THE TIME HOW
ATHLETES ARE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL AND EARNING THEIR DEGREE
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THEY
HAVE TO WAIT.
I'M SUGGESTING THAT THERE IS A
RECORD THAT IS IMMENSE I'M AN
OLYMPIAN.
I'M ALSO AN OLYMPIC COACH.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT OUR POOL OF
ATHLETES THEY COME FROM THE
UNIVERSITY THAT IS OUR POOL OF
ATHLETES.
AND THOSE ATHLETES.
I SPECIFICALLY COACH THE SPRINT
AS WELL AS THE HURDLES.
THAT SEEM TO HAVE THE LARGER
MINORITY BASE.
THESE ARE KIDS THAT WERE JUST
LIKE ME [inaudible]
GREW UP.
NOT NECESSARILY HAVING A FULL
SCHOLARSHIP WHAT WAS IN THE
ELITE ATHLETE BUT HAD TO WORK
OUR WAY.
WE HAD TO WORK OUR WAY.
SO MY LIKENESS MY BRANDING
WASN'T AN OPTION.
IT WASN'T UNTIL.
I WENT ON TO THE NCAA
CHAMPIONSHIP AND ONE THAT
PERHAPS THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY.
BUT IF I COMPARE MYSELF. TO A
FOOTBALL ATHLETE A BASKETBALL
ATHLETE.
OR BASEBALL ATHLETE MY LIKENESS
WOULD STILL NOT ALLOW ME.
THE COST OF LIVING NOR MY FAMILY.
SO I'M SPEAKING TO BACK GROUP OF
FOLK.
THAT LOWER LEVEL MADE MAKE ME IT
MADE MAJOR TYPE OF GROUP.
AND LONG BEACH STATE IS
DEFINITELY A MID MAJOR SPORT WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO CONTENT.
WILL PUT OUR STUDENT ATHLETES
PERHAPS EVEN IN A DEFICIT IN
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE DEFICIT
FINANCIAL DEFICIT.
IF CALIFORNIA SAYS.
THAT WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO PASS
THIS LEGISLATION.
THEN THE NC A A SAYS YOU GUYS
ARE NO LONGER A MEMBER OF
WHATEVER VIOLATIONS THAT WE HAVE.
HAVE HAVE INDULGED.
WHERE THOSE ATHLETES GOING TO
CALL?
THE PUT THEIR FAMILIES IN THE
SITUATION WHICH THEY HAVE TO
LOOK FURTHER.
OUT OF STATE USING OUT OF STATE
COSTS.
SO I JUST WANTED.
TO HAVE YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T BELIEVE.
THAT ATHLETES SHOULD BE
COMPENSATED. FOR THEIR OWN
LIKENESS.
I'M AN ATHLETE.
THROUGH AND THROUGH I BELIEVE
THAT.
BUT JUST NOT IN THIS MANNER.
PERHAPS MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY AT
THE STATE MANA BUT MAYBE.
MAYBE AT THE NCAA.
AND LET'S NOT PUT A TORCH ON IN
CA AND THEN WE'D BE CASUALTIES.
LOW KICK FROM LOS ANGELES.
INNER CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COACH.
AND AND AN EXCELLENT.
HI MY NAME IS THE MY MCDONALD --
FORMER SOCCER PLAYER ABOUT A
MONTH REMOVED AT THIS POINT FROM
THE LONG FROM ON THE STATE --
AND I'M HERE TO OPPOSE SB TWO OH
SIX FROM THE SOON ATHLETE
PERSPECTIVE JUST BECAUSE IT
HURTS MY OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED
TO ME THROUGH THE ATHLETIC
PROGRAM.
MY TH	C AGE BUT AID PACKAGE
HAS HELPED ME ATTENDED TO MY
DEGREE AS WELL AS MANY OF MY
FELLOW STUDENT ATHLETES.
THROUGH THE ATHLETICS EXPERIENCE
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BECOME A CITY A CS YOU'LL BE
SENATOR AT LARGE.
ARE BIG WEST CONFERENCE -- SENT
STUDENT ATHLETE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
A REPRESENTATIVE AND ENGAGE AS A
STUDENT LEADER ALL THROUGHOUT
OUR CAMPUS.
I HAVE ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAVEL TO PANAMA ON A SERVICE
TRIP ALONG SIDE MY THOUGHT IT
PROGRAM FAMILY.
AS A WOMAN OF COLOR ON THE
SOCCER FIELD I AM A MINORITY IN
THE MOST IN MOST SECTORS THAT I
ENTER.
YEAH THE L. B. S. U. ATHLETIC
PROGRAM HAS GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT I MAY NOT HAVE
DONE ON MY OWN WITHOUT PLAYING
THE SPORT THAT I LOVE.
WITH THE PASSING OF SB TWO OH
SIX I FEAR THAT WOMEN THAT COME
AFTER ME.
AND THE POSSIBILITIES BEING FAR
MORE LIMITED THAN OPPORTUNITIES
I'VE HAD -- IT WAS ALSO
MENTIONED THAT.
WHAT LIKE WHAT ATHLETE WOULD NOT
LIKE TO BE PAID FOR BY LIKE
MISSING COMPENSATION?
BUT AS WE SEE RIGHT NOW IN THE
WOMEN'S WORLD CUP THOSE WOMEN
ARE FIGHTING TO BE PAID THE
EQUAL AMOUNTS SO WHAT IT WHAT
ABOUT A GIRL FROM.
WHO WENT TO THE LOCAL COLLEGE?
I'M FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I
AM AT LONG BEACH THROUGH AND
THROUGH GIRL.
LOVE THE FIVE SIX TWO SO WHAT
MAKES YOU THINK IF WOMEN.
THE PROFESSIONAL LEVEL.
WOULD GET PAID THE SAME THEY
WOULD LIKE AYE I CAN'T GO TO MY
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE ME ANY
MONEY IS BASICALLY WHAT I'M
SAYING.
I'M NOT GONNA MAKE ANY MONEY OFF
MY IMAGE OR LIKENESS BECAUSE I'M
NOTHING.
TO YOU ALL.
I AM.
I LOVE MYSELF.
BUT I'M WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY
IS THAT THE WOMAN AT THE
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL CANNOT GET A
PROPER PLAYING SURFACE TO PLAY
ON AND IF THEY ARE NOT AFFORDED
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE
GIVE OUR MAN THAT WE GIVE.
THE U. S. MEN'S NATIONAL TEAM
AND THEY'RE FIGHTING FOR THE
SAME.
LEG UP WHEN THEY ARE ABOUT TO BE
FOUR TIME WORLD FULL WORLD CUP
CHAMPIONS.
I'M NOT GONNA BE AFFORDED THE
SAME.
THE SAME RIGHTS.
SO WHERE WERE PLAYING ON THE
BACK OF THESE MEN MAJOR STUDENT
ATHLETES AND MY AID PACKAGE HAS --
TREMENDOUSLY HELPED ME.
I STILL HAD TO WORK BUT ASKED
MENTAL HELP HELP ME AND I'M
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE WITH.
A BACHELORS OF ARTS AND I'M
GOING TO GO GET A MASTERS.
BUT I'M NOT IN ANY DEBT.
AND THAT'S SO NICE THAT'S SO
NICE AND IN COMPARISON TO MY
COUNTERPARTS.
MIKE THAT THEY HAVE MINIMAL DEBT
AND COMPARED TO SOME OF OUR NON
ATHLETIC COUNTERPARTS THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP THE
EQUAL PAY DE SHOE. TO FALL
ELECTION THOUGH WITH A FEW.
TO IT WAS A A POSSIBLE WITHOUT --
ANY COMPENSATION LIKE TO GET A
PICTURE WITH YOU LATER.
ALL RIGHT BEFORE -- BY CALL ON
THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO WOULD ASK THE SECRETARY.
TO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
KANSEN CHU HERE KANSEN CHU HERE
DEEP [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
CHOICE HERE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HERE COM WATER TO COME
LONGER DEATH HERE THIS AREA.
THIS AREA HERE.
RIGHT GREAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME.
FOR GOOD MORNING ALEX GRAYS WITH
THE ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES
REPRESENT EIGHTY FOUR PRIVATE
NONPROFIT SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
NINE AT THE DIVISION ONE LEVEL
NINE DIVISION TO LEVEL IN
THIRTEEN AT THE DIVISION THREE
LEVEL NANCY TWO WAY -- IF I
COULD JUST ADD THAT -- YOU KNOW
OUR INSTITUTIONS LOOK AT THIS
FROM A PERSPECTIVE OF IF THIS
GOES THROUGH NEEDING TO TAKE A
UTILITARIAN.
PERSPECTIVE AN APPROACH TO THE
THE RISKS THAT -- POSES TO OUR
STUDENT ATHLETES AND WHAT WE
BELIEVE WILL BENEFIT A VERY
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF STUDENT
ATHLETES -- WEIGHED AGAINST THE
POTENTIAL HARM TO MANY OF OUR
STUDENT ATHLETES -- I THINK
THERE'S SOME OTHER THINGS ARE
BROUGHT UP THAT THAT
CHARACTERIZES -- NO LONGER
ACCURATE IN TERMS OF THE NC TO A
BUT WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND DISCUSS THAT
FURTHER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JANET LOW BECAUSE REPRESENTING
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN A I SEE SEE
YOU MEMBER SCHOOL.
AND H. STAND HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW TO WE DID WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY TWELVE TO
PASS A STUDENT ATHLETE BILL OF
RIGHTS.
AT THAT TIME OUR FOOTBALL
PROGRAMS GRADUATION RATE WAS AT
58% IT IS NOW IT'S 75%.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ENTER MARTINEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY WHICH YOUR OPPOSED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RYAN MAC LANEY TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ATHLETIC ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING TYLER I YOU ARMY AFTER
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFUL IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
RUNNING FEEL LEVELS WITH
STANFORD UNIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION I DO JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT I THINK MANY OF THE
COLLEGES WOULD SHARE SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS REGARDING NAME
IMAGE AND LIKENESS.
WE'RE JUST CONCERNED AND OPPOSE
THE PROCESS SO IN IN AND THE
REST THAT IT PLACES ON
INSTITUTIONS AND STUDENTS --
ABILITY TO PLAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ON UNDERSTAND A
WOULD TO HAVE A LATE OPPOSITION
LET HER.
THE SERGEANTS COUNTLESS PASSION
ALL.
AT THIS POINT -- LIKE -- TO OPEN
UP -- FOR DETAILS FOR ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MOM.
I MEAN YOU MEMBERS.
ONLY GOOD ALL.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU.
TO SENATOR SKINNER AND BRADFORD --
FOR BRINGING THIS HIGHLY NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILLED TO OUT.
AT I ACTUALLY HAD A QUESTION --
FOR THE ON POSITION BEFORE I
MAKE MY COMMENTS AND I WANTED TO
KNOW THAT -- DO STUDENTS WHO ARE
ON PARTIAL SCHOLARSHIP OR WHO
ARE RECEIVING NO SCHOLARSHIP AT
ALL WHO ARE ATHLETES DO THEY
ALSO HAVE TO ABIDE BY THE NC
DOUBLE A RULES [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY -- SO I'M.
GOING I HAVE TO SAY I REPRESENT --
WENT TO A GREAT SCHOOL THAT HAS --
A PHENOMENAL -- ATHLETIC PROGRAM
AND REPRESENT A GREAT SCHOOL --
THAT HAS A PHENOMENAL ATHLETIC
PROGRAM.
OKAY -- AND HAVE HEARD FROM THEM --
AND I'VE ALSO HEARD FROM THE
STUDENT ATHLETES AT THOSE
SCHOOLS AS WELL AND I I DO WANT
TO JUST SAY THAT I THINK WE'RE
CONFLATING SO MANY ISSUES WHEN
YOU SORT OF TALK ABOUT THIS --
THE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT JUST
KIND OF EQUITY -- ON CAMPUSES
BETWEEN STUDENT ATHLETES AND NON
STUDENT ATHLETES YOU'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND INCOME AND
DISPARITY -- AND AND WHO
ACTUALLY NEEDS A SCHOLARSHIP
YOU'RE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT IF STUDENTS ARE EMPLOYEES
OR NOT I MEAN I THINK THE
NORTHWESTERN RULING WAS A GREAT
EXAMPLE AN INDICATIVE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE ARE HAVING --
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ABOUT YOU
KNOW OUR STUDENT ATHLETES
ALREADY.
ARE PAID TO PLAY YOU KNOW.
THEY HAVE -- TO SHOW UP AND DO
THE TRAINING AND WORK WITH THEIR
COLLEAGUES THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS REGIMENT OR ELSE.
AND MANY OF THEM LOOK A CERTAIN
KIND OF WAY AND MANY OF THEM
COME FROM -- CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
AND THEN YOU HAVE AND AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOME SOME OF THAT --
SPORTS PLOT PAY.
FOR NOT ONLY THE OTHER SPORTS
BUT ALSO PAY FOR ALL OF THE
OTHER THINGS THAT REVENUE IS
JUST NOT BEING GENERATED TO
COVER ON THESE CAMPUSES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE IN CA.
YOU KNOW IN AS I HAVE READ
THROUGH MULTIPLE PAGES OF
ARTICLES ON THE NC A A AND ITS
PUNISHMENTS AND THE PROHIBITIONS
AND HOW FOLKS OF LOST
ELIGIBILITY.
YOU KNOW IT'S RIGHT OUT OF THE
GODFATHER MOVIE.
YOU KNOW AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND -- THOSE
KINDS OF PROHIBITIONS AN
ELIGIBILITY I THINK THE FACT
THAT -- BAN IN YOU KNOW -- HAD
TO GET THE CALL FROM HIS FRIEND
WHO'S PLAYING THIS VIDEO GAME
AND SAYS HEY I'M ACTUALLY
PLAYING A GAME AND THIS IS YOU.
YOU KNOW AND HAD TO TAKE THAT TO
COURT.
BECAUSE HE HE HAD NOT BENEFITED
FINANCIALLY FROM HIS AMATEUR
CAREER [inaudible]
RIGHT.
NOT TO MENTION ALL OF THESE
OTHERS I MEAN AND THE LIST GOES
ON AND ON DONNIE EDWARDS.
WE HAD REGGIE BUT I MEAN ALL OF
THESE FOLKS WE HAVE TO HAVE A
SERIOUS CONVERSATION ABOUT A HOW
THE NC A A AND BY THE WAY I
THINK THE NCAA IS ACTUALLY A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION YES
COMPRISED OF THE SCHOOLS AND SO
IN MY MIND.
JUST LIKE A UNION.
THE SCHOOLS ACTUALLY HAVE THE
POWER IN THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL HAVE THE
POWER IN PERSUADING THE IN CA TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT.
THE RULINGS THAT IT WANTS TO
GIVE OUT.
I ALSO THINK THERE'S SOME YOU
KNOW WE SHOULD KIND OF BE
TALKING ABOUT THAT I'VE HEARD
ABOUT THIS COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE THAT SCHOOLS WILL
FACE IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW OTHER SCHOOLS AND OTHER
STATES WILL SORT OF POACH THESE
ATHLETES AND TAKE THEM BECAUSE
OF THIS RULING?
AND I ACTUALLY SEE IT IN ANOTHER
WAY -- I THINK THAT THERE WILL
BE A COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE HELD
BY THE SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHO SAY IF YOU COME TO ONE OF
OUR COLLEGES WE ARE GOING?
TO WE HAVE THIS STRUCTURE SET UP
IN PLACE.
WHERE -- IF IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
BENEFIT OFF OF YOUR LIKENESS IN
YOUR IMAGE YOU CAN.
MANY OF THE YOUNG FOLKS NOWADAYS
ARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS -- TO
EARN ADDITIONAL REVENUE -- AND
TO BENEFIT FROM THEIR BRANDING I
CERTAINLY DON'T THINK THAT IN CA
DOUBLE AGE SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
AND HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DECIDE
THAT IMAGE AND HOW IT'S USED.
AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
BECAUSE THE NCA A IS SAYING WELL
YOU KNOW IF WE ALLOW THESE
ATHLETES TO BENEFIT AND HAVE
THIS COMPENSATION THEN WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE VIEWERS WERE GONNA
LOSE REVENUE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO
WATCH BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
SAY THESE ARE BECAUSE I
PROFESSIONALS.
YOU KNOW IN MY MIND THAT SORT OF
I CAN TO SORT OF PRICE GOUGING --
AND SO I JUST HAVE SIRIUS SIRIUS
CONCERNS AND I AM HOPEFUL JUST
LIKE I HEARD SENATOR PAN SAY
THAT WE CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW OUR SCHOOLS ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE HELPING AND
SUPPORTING THE STUDENTS.
RATHER THAN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW HOW TO SORT OF A BITE
BY ARBITRARY DECISIONS COMING
FROM THE NCAA AS IT RELATES TO
THEIR OWN ABILITY TO MAKE NEW
REVENUE.
AND SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS [inaudible]
QUESTION.
SURE WELL FIRST I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE WITNESSES FOR COMING
HERE TODAY AND I'M SPEAKING AND
SHARING YOUR VERY IMPRESSIVE
STORIES -- WAS NOT A STUDENT
ATHLETE I WAS ON THE DEBATE TEAM
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT COUNTS.
A SIMILAR RIGHT -- YEAH YEAH.
YEAH -- YOU KNOW I I THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE DIFFICULT BILLS WERE
EVERYBODY WANTS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR OUR STUDENTS BUT
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES BASED ON KIND OF
WHAT THEIR PATH HAS BEEN.
SO -- I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT THE
BILL'S AUTHORS WHO ARE VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT HELPING
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSION AS THIS GOES
FORWARD -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF
FINDING WAYS TO GIVE TO OPEN UP
OUR OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
STUDENTS -- WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU HAVE SPOKEN SO
ELOQUENTLY ABOUT NEEDING TO
PROTECT YOU KNOW I'LL JUST ADD
THE COMMENT THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW SADDAM THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
STUDENTS WHO.
ARE MISSY.
ARM.
THESE SPORTS AS KIND OF THEIR
TICKET INTO THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM OR TO YOU KNOW A MUCH
BETTER LIFE -- NOT EVERY
STUDENTS GOING TO END UP BEING
AN ELITE ATHLETE A PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETE -- AND YOU KNOW HAVING
NO WATCHED THE WONDERFUL
DOCUMENTARY SOME YEARS AGO WAS
HOOP DREAMS YOU KNOW THERE
THERE'S A SAID SORT OF A SADNESS
AND AS DESPERATION DOESN'T TO A
LOT OF THIS.
AND ALSO CERTAINLY SOME
EXPLOITATION THAT HAPPENS WITH
THE STUDENTS I'M WITH
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES -- THAT
YOU KNOW MAKES ALL OF THIS A TON
OF A DIFFICULT MORE DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION AND GIVEN THAT IT'S
OVERLAID WITH PEOPLE WHO JUST
WANT TO EDUCATION I WANT A
BETTER LIFE AND SOMETIMES HAVE
TROUBLE ACHIEVING THAT.
YOU KNOW I CAN'T HELP BUT THINK
THAT PART OF OUR CONVERSATION
ALSO HAS TO CONTINUE TO BE ABOUT
HAVING TO OPEN HOW TO OPEN UP
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT MORE
CALIFORNIA'S.
CHILDREN CAN HAVE A GOOD COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND THAT YOU KNOW
FINANCES DON'T BECOME THAT
BARRIER.
AND YOU KNOW ON THE OTHER THING
I WAS THINKING WAS THAT IT'S
UNFAIR THAT.
YOU KNOW ALL OF YOU HAVE -- TO
BE WITH YOUR SUPPORT SEEN AS YOU
KNOW KIND OF LESSER THEM YOU
KNOW THAT WOMEN'S SPORTS ARE NOT
GIVEN THE SAME ATTENTION AND IT --
AND OPPORTUNITIES AS MEN WHO
PLAY SPORTS AND YOU KNOW WITH
SOMEONE WITH A DAUGHTER YOU KNOW
THAT SAD THAT SHE MAY END UP
BEING AN ATHLETE WHO DOESN'T
HAVE AS GOOD A PLAYING FIELD AS
THE BOYS DO.
SO THAT'S NO DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION AND THIS BILL IS
NOT GOING TO ADDRESS THAT -- AND
YOU KNOW WE JUST HAVE TO KEEP
WORKING TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T
NEGATIVELY IMPACT WHAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE AS YOU YOU KNOW AS
YOU STATED THOSE CONCERNS SO I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY AND
I'M.
YOU KNOW LOOKING FOR DECEIVING
SCENE A CONVERSATION BEFORE AND
I HOPE THAT YOU ARE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
YOU WILL.
YOU KNOW CONTINUE TO PUSH THIS
INTO THE RIGHT PLACE SO THANKS
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND DOCTOR CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR.
AND THE LISTENING [inaudible]
TO JUST ME.
WHAT SIZE SAW A E. AIR -- THE
CORE QUESTION MEAN IS
[inaudible]
ONCE WE INACTIVE THIS KIND OF A
LAW -- WE ARE CONFLICTING WITH
THE NC DOUBLE A REGULATIONS.
AND THE STUDENTS SO -- WILL GET
HURT.
AS LONG AS AT THE SCHOOL --
STAYS A AS A MEMBER AND THE
MAYBE.
EXPECTED -- SO WHAT.
YOUR ORIGINAL INTENT IS.
TO HELP STUDENTS ATHLETES.
SO THAT THAT THEY WOULD BE ON
THE SAME NAM.
PLAYING FIELD DOT UP BASED UPON
THE IMAGES OF WHAT LIKENESS.
LIKE THE ANY OTHER STUDENTS
HOWEVER.
IF YOU'D ON WORK OUT.
IN A DOORS SAID THE MEMBER
INVESTED CELL.
PHONE CONVINCED THE BLAZE INTO
W. -- WOULD NOT CHANGE -- BUT
THE LUCKILY -- HOPE YES THAT
THAT THEY MAY COME UP WITH A
SOME.
A GUIDE Là M<c.cyan> SOLUTION</c>
BECAUSE SAW WHAT I READ IS THAT
THAT THEY HAVE FORMED A WORKING
TASK FORCE.
AND THAT THEY ARE WORKING ON IT.
AND THE YOUR BILL PROPOSES.
THAT THE NOT EVEN THIS OF COURSE
INTO EFFECT THE IS NOT GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE THAT'S
A QUITE A FEW YEARS.
SO FROM NOW 1-220-00 WHATEVER
NOT TWENTY THREE OF THE TASK
FORCE TO MAY COME UP WITH IS
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO I WONDER WHY -- WE TRY TO
CONFRONT WITH THE NC DOUBLE A
AND A PUT THE ATHLETES IN FACT
THE IN JEOPARDY OF THE FUTURE
POTENTIAL.
IN ALL OF POLL BECAUSE ONCE YOU
VIOLATE UP FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE OLD THE BED THE FROM
JOINING.
IN A FEW JOKES IN ALL PROTEINS.
SO WHAT YOUR INTENT IS SAW.
NOT SO WELL KNOWN.
I SUPPORTED THE BECAUSE OF THE
THE THE THE FIRST STEP IS -- TO
TO I AM NOT IN THE COME UP WITH
THE A WORK BURKE AGREEMENT WITH
THE NC DOUBLE A RATHER THAN JUST
A PUSHING.
AND OF FIGHT AND UP BUT THE
ATHLETES SO IN IN THE JEOPARDY --
THROUGH THE CHAIR IF I COULD
RESPOND -- A COUPLE THINGS FIRST
THERE WAS A VERY -- A VERY
LIVELY AND I THOUGHT VERY
PRODUCTIVE EXCHANGE AT THE
SENATE ED COMMITTEE BETWEEN
DOCTOR PAN AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF COLLEGES
WHERE HE ASTOR BERRIES REPRESENT
OF THE COLLEGES.
WHAT IS THE BOARD OF THE NCQA
ART AREN'T YOU THE NC TWO WAY?
AND THEY SAID YES IT IS MADE UP
OF COLLEGES.
AND SO IT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE
RIGHT NOW THAT THE NC TO A IS
THREATENING CALIFORNIA AND WE
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES OF OUR
COLLEGES COMING.
BECAUSE OF THIS CONCERN OF THAT
THREAT BUT IT IS COLLEGES
THREATENING THEMSELVES BECAUSE
THE NC TWO EIGHT IS COLLEGES NOW.
THE NC TWO EIGHT TRIES TO HIDE
BEHIND THAT.
AND YET THE COLLEGES THEMSELVES
COULD PLAY A STRONG ROLE IN
CHANGING THESE RULES.
THE SP TWO OH SIX IS NOT THE
VERY FIRST CONVERSATION AROUND
THIS ISSUE THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN
DOMINATING DISCUSSIONS WITH IN
COLLEGE ATHLETICS FOR YEARS.
AND THERE WAS PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA
LOOKED AT BACK AS EARLY AS I
BELIEVE.
TWO THOUSAND NOW EACH TIME THE
COLLEGES SAID YOU CAN'T PUT US
AT A DISADVANTAGE THE NC TO A
MAY RETALIATE IN THE NC TO A
WILL CHANGE THEIR RULES.
THE NC TO A HAS ONLY MINIMALLY
CHANGE THEIR RULES AND THE RULES
THEY HAVE CHANGE THUS FAR
LITERALLY ONLY BENEFIT ELITE
MALE ATHLETES.
SO WE HEAR NOW THE CONCERN.
WHICH I TOTALLY SHARE THIS
CONCERN THAT ARE FEMALE ATHLETES
ARE PUT AT SUCH A DISADVANTAGE.
BUT IN FACT THINK ABOUT IT FOR A
MOMENT.
THE VERY RULE OF IN SITU WAY
THAT DENIES ANY WOMAN COLLEGE
STUDENT FROM MARKETING HERSELF.
BASICALLY SERVES TO NOT ONLY
HURT HER BUT HURT THE ENTIRE
POSSIBILITY OF FEMALE ATHLETES
IN FEMALE SPORTS BECOMING A
BIGGER.
A BIGGER FORCE WITHIN OUR
ECONOMIC MARKET PLACE AND OUR
CULTURE.
AND YET THESE WOMEN ARE THEIR
ONLY TIME OF REALLY BEING ABLE
TO BE IN THE LIMELIGHT IS DURING
COLLEGE BECAUSE THERE'S SO FEW
PRO OPPORTUNITIES SO LET'S TAKE
COURT CAITLYN OR HOW SHE FOR A
MOMENT.
THE UCLA GYMNAST.
SHE HAS IF YOU LOOK ON YOUTUBE
MILLIONS OF YOU TO VIEWERS
MILLIONS NOW ANY OTHER STUDENTS
COULD MARKET THEMSELVES WITH
THOSE MILLIONS OF YOUTUBE YOURS.
AND BE ABLE TO MONETIZE IT SHE
CANNOT.
WILL SHE BE ABLE TO GO PRO AFTER
THE POSSIBILITY IS VERY IS LOW
IT'S POSSIBLE BUT LOW.
I'M YET SHE COULD UNDER THESE
RULES SHE COULD HAVE
[inaudible]
POTENTIALLY MONETIZED THAT THE
PHENOMENAL YOU TO VIEWERS THAT
SHE GOT WE HEARD FROM ERIN
CAFARO AS A ROWER SHE DIDN'T
EVEN GET A SCHOLARSHIP UNTIL HER
SENIOR YEAR AND ONLY A PARTIAL
SCHOLARSHIP.
DURING THE TIME THAT SHE WAS
ROWING FOR CAL.
AND BEING LOOKED AT AS A
POTENTIAL OLYMPIC ATHLETE WHO
SHE LATER BECAME AND WAS A GOLD
MEDAL STARK.
WE WE CANNOT RIGHT NOW SIT HERE
AND SAY THAT THERE WAS NO ONE
WHO MIGHT HAVE SPONSORED HER.
HER LOCAL QANTAS CLUB OR ROTARY
CLUB MIGHT HAVE BEEN WILLING TO
SPONSOR HER WHEN SHE DID NOT
HAVE A SCHOLARSHIP AND HELP HER
COVER HER COSTS.
BUT THAT IS DENIED SO.
I SAY THAT THE NC TO A IN THERE
MAKING THESE THREATS TO
CALIFORNIA.
IS PUTTING THIS CHILLING EFFECT
AND COULD CAUSE SOME OF YOU FILL
UP WE CAN'T CHANGE THE RULES.
BUT IN FACT THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO GIVE NC TWO WAY TO
CHANGE THE RULES AND TO GIVE OUR
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES.
THE ABILITY TO ADVOCATE FOR OUR
STUDENTS. TO ADVOCATE FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THERE WAS A TWITTER STORM
YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE OF THE USA TO TODAY
ARTICLE AND THE FIRST TIME THE
NC TWO EIGHT MADE PUBLIC THEIR
THREATS.
AND THEN NOT TWITTER STORM AND I
THINK YOU ALL HAVE A COPY.
PEOPLE TO SET YOU KNOW THE NC
TWO WAY IS COLLEGES THE NC TO A
COULD CHANGE THESE ROLES.
DE UM COMMISSION OR TASK FORCE
THAT THE OF STARTED WAS
LITERALLY STARTED DUE TO THE
FACT THAT SB TWO OH SIX PASSED
THE SENATE AND THERE'S NOW
CONGRESSIONAL LEGISLATION AND
OTHER STATES LOOKING AT THIS.
WE HAVE THE TIME TO BRING THIS
TOGETHER AND I DIDN'T MENTION IN
MY OPENING.
THAT I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS.
WHERE WE ARE WE HAVE BUILT INTO
THE BILL WITH THE A CHAIR
SUGGESTION WE HAVE BUILT INTO
THE BILL THAT IN THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD BEFORE THE BILL WOULD
TAKE A FACT?
THAT WE WOULD MONITOR WE
CALIFORNIA WOULD MONITOR THE
CHANGES THAT NC TO A MATE AND WE
COULD COME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
AND REVISE OUR RULES AS
ACCORDINGLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A CHAIR I
HAVE A JUST A FOLLOW UP COUPLE
MORE QUESTIONS -- THAT IS -- I'M
SURPRISED AT HOW COME NC THE
PLAY REPRESENTATIVE I DON'T KNOW
IF US IN THE AUDIENCE SO WOULD
NOT COME HERE TO SPEAK ON THEIR
BEHALF.
IS THE ANY MEMBER FROM AND SEE
THE PLAY HOME IS ASIAN.
COLLEGE.
JUST COLLEGES OKAY THEY ARE THE
AMOUNT ON TODAY'S.
SACRAMENTO BEAT THAT THE PATTERN
SAYS SO AND TO DOUBLE LADY COULD
BAN CALIFORNIA COLLEGES TO FROM
BOARD GAMES SO AND A TORN MUSCLE
AWFUL PROPOSED -- ETHNIC BAY.
CHAU.
IF.
YOU HAVE NATION THAT THEY'VE
BEEN VERY RESISTANT FOR FOR FOR
A LONG TIME.
IF FOR THEY WILL NOT.
BUT CHECK AND THE CONFRONTATION
OF TO CALIFORNIA LAW.
HOW WOULD YOU HANDLE THIS KIND
OF THE SITUATIONS WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD? TO REVISIT THE ISSUE IN
THE PERIOD OF TIME THAT T. M..
THAT WE'VE GIVEN THE NC TWO
EIGHT TO BE ABLE TO DELIBERATE.
BUT I I JUST WANT US TO KIND OF
STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT AND THINK
FOR A MINUTE.
IMAGINE IF ANY OTHER.
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY USED
COLLEGE STUDENTS AS THE SOURCE
OF THEIR REVENUE.
TV MOVIES ANY YET DENIED
STUDENTS ANY ABILITY TO SHARE IN
THAT WERE TO RECEIVE ANY TYPE OF
COMPENSATION OR MONETIZE.
THERE WOULD BE UNIVERSAL OUTCRY.
AND YET THESE ARE THE CONDITIONS
THAT AND SEE TO A HAS SET UP.
AND THEY ARE A BILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY IN FACT THE TV NETWORKS.
NC TO WEIGH IN THE COLLEGES THE
MEDIA OUTLETS THE SPORTS APPAREL
COMPANIES THE VIDEO GAME MAKERS
ALL OF THEM MONETIZE THE COLLEGE
ATHLETES THE STUDENTS.
AND YET THE STUDENTS CANNOT IN
ANY OTHER INDUSTRY THAT WAS
MONETIZING THE COLLEGE STUDENT.
AND THEY DID NOT AND THEY DENIED
STUDENTS YOU WOULD HAVE
INCREDIBLE OUTCRY.
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE WITH ARMAGEDDON
THREATS FROM ENTRENCHED
INTERESTS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
AMAZON WHEN WE DID LEGISLATION
TO STOP THEIR ANTI COMPETITIVE
AN UNFAIR COLLECTION REFUSAL TO
COLLECT SALES TAX.
THERE WAS ALL KINDS OF CHRIST
THAT WE WERE DESTROYING THE
INTERNET THAT WE WERE YOU KNOW
THE ARMY GRETTON THREATS.
NOTHING HAD HAPPENED.
AMAZON IS BIGGER THAN EVER
INTERNET SALES IN OUR LARGER
THAN RETAIL SALES CORPORATIONS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAID THEY WOULD LEAVE
CALIFORNIA WHEN WE PASSED THE
LAW THAT REQUIRED GENDER PAY
EQUITY.
THEY DID NOT.
THERE'S BEEN THREATS OF JOB LOSS
IN ECONOMIC DOOM WHEN CALIFORNIA
ADOPTED BOLD CLIMATE CHANGE LAWS
AND YET WERE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY OF THE WORLD WE HAVE THE
BOLDEST CLIMATE CHANGE LAWS.
WE WITHSTOOD ALL OF THOSE
WITHOUT DOOMSDAY CONSEQUENCES
THIS IS WHAT CALIFORNIA DOES WE
LEAD AND WE LEAD WITH OUR VALUES.
ALEX GRAYS THE ICY CO -- I JUST
WANNA MAKE ONE OR TWO BRIEF
COMMENTS IF I MAY UM.
FIRST OF ALL THE BAND DECISION
ON OTHER THINGS LEAD TO THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MONETIZATION
OF THESE ATHLETES FOR VIDEO
GAMES -- STUDENT ATHLETES CAN
PROFIT -- OUTSIDE ABOUT LET X. --
JOSH LAMB FROM THE FENCING TEAM
AT DUKE WAS ALLOWED YOU THE SAME
IMAGE LIKE THIS PROMOTE A
COMPANY -- THAT HE DEVELOPED.
AND AND THERE ARE ADDITIONAL --
OPPORTUNITIES IN WAIVERS FOR
STUDENTS TO BENEFIT -- OUTSIDE
ABOUT POLITICS -- THAT
ADDITIONALLY IN REGARDS TO WHAT
WE ARE THE NC TWO WAY I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT WE ARE YES WE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE AND TEACH YOU A
AND I THINK WHATEVER.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON IN SITU WAY --
YOU KNOW THE INSTITUTIONS ARE IN
A I WOULD SAY SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
POSITION AT ALL THIS IN IN SITU
A IS AN ORGANIZATION -- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TWENTY FOUR DIVISION ONE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE -- IN CA
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
I THINK THREE HUNDRED FIFTY ONE
DIVISION ONE PROGRAMS NATIONALLY --
WE DO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE -- THROUGH -- V.
CONFERENCES AND THROUGH OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT SUCH AS THAT AND
CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS HAVE
SUPPORTED A NUMBER OF
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THE AG STAND
BENEFITS THE STUDENT ATHLETES --
WE'VE SUPPORTED POLICY CHANGE
THE PERMIT INSTITUTIONS TO PASTE
IN ATHLETES UP TO THE FULL COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
THAT WAS I THINK FOR SO FOR FIVE
YEARS AGO -- AS WELL AS PROVIDE
A STIPEND TO COVER PERSONAL
EXPENSES AND TRAVEL THE HOME.
OUR INSTITUTIONS OF SUPPORT
MOVING TO GUARANTEE MULTIPLE
YOUR SCHOLARSHIPS TO STUDENTS AS
WELL AS REPLACEMENT SCHOLARSHIPS.
THEY GET INJURED AS WELL AS
ENHANCE MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH
COVERAGE.
WE'VE ALSO INCREASE THAT STUDENT
ATHLETES PARTICIPATION IN THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE FOR EXAMPLE
THE WEST COAST CONFERENCE WHICH
SEVEN OF OUR MEMBERS --
PARTICIPATING SO IT'S LIKE THE
U. OPIES SANTA CLARA AS
UNIVERSITY SAN DIEGO'S -- IN
LAST YEAR ADDED A STUDENT
ATHLETE FROM EACH INSTITUTION IS
A VOTING MEMBER -- IN THAT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE.
CURRENTLY THIS YEAR WERE
SUPPORTING AB FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS A BILL THAT YOU'VE
AUTHORED -- THAT WOULD ALLOW
LEAD STUDENT ATHLETES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLORE
PROFESSIONAL OPPORTUNITIES --
WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING THEIR
ABILITY TO COME BACK IF THEY YOU
KNOW GO EXPLORE THAT REALIZE
THAT THEY THEY PERHAPS -- OR NOT
IS WELL POSITIONED ATTRACTED IS
PERHAPS THEY IMAGINE THEY MIGHT
BE -- I THINK IN JUST LASTLY
WITH THE THE NC TO A WORKING
GROUP YOU KNOW THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE COMING OUT
IN OCTOBER -- WE'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
RECOMMENDED POLICY CHANGES
AROUND THESE ISSUES -- GIVEN
THERE'S A DELAY TILL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IMPLEMENTATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS NOT
HARM IN PUSHING THIS
CONVERSATION BACK INTO EARLY
NEXT YEAR TO SEE WHAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE AND WHERE WE
CAN HAVE ALIGNMENT -- BECAUSE
AGAIN YOU KNOW OUR SCHOOLS.
YOU KNOW IF YOUR STUDENT ATHLETE
AND YOU RECEIVE COMPENSATION.
I I I WOULD SAY THAT IT IS GOING
TO PUT YOU IN A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE BECAUSE AGAIN AT THE
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
EVALUATE IF YOU HAVE ONE STUDENT
ATHLETE BEING PAID IF YOU ALLOW
THEM TO COMPETE.
THEIR ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THE ENTIRE PROGRAM VACATE WINS
YOU'RE AN ELIGIBLE FOR
POSTSEASON PLAY -- YOU ALSO FACE
YOU KNOW SCHOOLS ARE OF REQUIRED
TO SELF REPORT VIOLATIONS -- AND
IF YOU'RE REPEAT VIOLATOR IF YOU
HAVE YOU KNOW STUDENT ATHLETES
ACROSS MULTIPLE SPORTS READ YOU
KNOW MULTIPLE OUTLETS IN ONE
SPORT.
WHO ARE AT COMPETING RECEIVES
COMPENSATION YOU FACE THE
POSSIBILITY OF LOS COLLAR SHIPS
WHICH IS THAT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FUTURE STUDENT ATHLETES THAT ARE
NOT NO LONGER AVAILABLE -- SO
AGAIN FROM THAT UTILITARIAN
PERSPECTIVE I THINK OUR SCHOOLS
ARE GOING TO FEEL AS THOUGH IF
THERE IS A STUDENT ATHLETE THAT
THEY KNOW IS RECEIVING
COMPENSATION FOR THE NAME IMAGE
AND LIKENESS THAT STUDENT
ATHLETES NOT TO BE ALLOWED TO
COMPETE.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE OTHER
STUDENT ATHLETES THAT TEAM AND
THEIR ABILITY TO LISTEN ABOUT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WILL DEFINITELY WILL
GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES.
THE THREE YEAR HOLD IF YOU WILL
WITH THE BAT WHERE THE THE THE
BILL WILL BE -- KINDA AND THAT
OUR RECRUITING.
WHAT ATHLETE WOULD WANT TO COME
[inaudible] TO CALIFORNIA IF
WE'RE NOT A MEMBER OF THE
INSTITUTION [inaudible]
THEY'RE NOT.
JUST ONE VERY BRIEF COMMENT TO
EXPAND ON THAT.
IN THE RECRUITING WORLD.
WE ARE RECRUITING INTO THE HIGH
SCHOOL AGES SO WE ARE RECRUITING
SEE ATHLETES WHO WOULD BE THE
INCOMING CLASS OF TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWO COACHES
COMMENTS.
IF YOU WERE FORCED INTO DECISION
WHERE.
SCHOOL A IN CALIFORNIA -- SCHOOL
BE AND ARIZONA FOR EXAMPLE AND
YOU WERE TOLD.
WELL.
DON'T GO TO SCHOOL A IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE YOU WILL NOT
HAVE A SCHOLARSHIP WAITING FOR
YOU BECAUSE THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL.
THE POTENTIAL THAT UNIVERSITY
WOULD BE EXPELLED.
AND THERE ARE ONLY A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF ROSTER SPOTS ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT 800-021-0000 STUDENT
ATHLETES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALONE.
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO TAKE ALL THE STUDENT ATHLETES.
SO THERE WILL BE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS MADE IN THIS INTERIM
PERIOD SO THERE IS A HARMONISED
SHORT RUN.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH EARNS
THANK YOU FOR THE WITNESSES FORK --
TRAVEL ALL THE WAY FROM LONG
BEACH AND SAN DIEGO TO TESTIFY.
AT ALL I HAD -- EXTENSIVE CON
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL I'M OWN COME VERY
CONFIDENCE THAT -- SENATOR
SKINNER UNDERSTOOD.
THE SHE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
AND THAT YOU SHOULD -- WAS
BROUGHT UP A FULL WERE BY BY THE
OPPOSITION.
AND ALSO -- THANK HER FOR TAKING
THE MAMMON TO KIND OF LEAVE THE
CONVERSATION -- OPEN WE WILL
DEFINITELY EXAM TO USE TO
RELATING TO THIS ROUTE OCTOBER
RULING FROM AN UNKNOWN NC DOUBLE
A AND WOOD -- WILL DEFINITELY
YOU WHO WILL REVERSE IT AS USUAL --
ON IMPLEMENTATION SUFFICIENT
FUNDIE AND AND RECOMMENDATION SO --
ARE I WOULD BE SUPPORTING THIS --
TO THE EARTH THIS BILL I I JUST
HAD A ONE QUICK QUESTION FOR THE
ATTORNEY FROM A SAN DIEGO.
I REMEMBER EARLY -- í
INDICATED THAT THIS IS ALREADY A
CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND SO OUR QUESTION IS IF IT'S
ALREADY A CALIFORNIA LAW
[inaudible]
NORTH CONNECT -- YOU HAVE.
ZERO ONE ARE YOU OKAY.
WELL WILL IT.
MY MY QUESTION IS YOU IF IT'S
ALREADY IN THE BOOK.
WHY DO WE NEED A BAIL?
OUT WHAT I MEANT TO SAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THAT IT IS ALREADY
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT EVERY
CITIZEN.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OF ANY AGE CAN ANY.
ARE.
STATUS EDGY STUDENT OR FOR
WORKER HAS THE RIGHT. TO
MONETIZE HIS NAME.
LIKENESS AND IMAGE HI DO YOU DO.
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD SOCCER PLAYERS
DO AND WHAT I SAID WAS IF I
DIDN'T SAY IT PROPERLY AND
MISLED YOU I APOLOGIZE WHAT I
SAID WAS.
THE THOSE FOLKS WHO WANT TO GO
TO COLLEGE HAVE TO GIVE UP THAT
LEGAL RIGHT.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
AND THE CALIFORNIA COURTS.
HAVE GIVEN THEM.
SO CALIFORNIA GIVES THEM THE
RIGHT. TO BENEFIT FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA TO HAVE SHOE CONTRACTS AND
HAVE ENDORSEMENTS.
BUT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TELLS THEM.
YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO PLAY HERE
IF YOU COME HERE YOU CAN
MATRICULATE YOU CAN BE A STUDENT.
YOU SIMPLY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
FOLLOW YOUR SUPPORT TOWARD
FORCES THEM INTO A STATION THAT
THEY WISH NOT TO HAVE TO MAKE.
ALL RIGHTS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO -- I THINK WE'RE READY.
TO TO CALL THE ROAD AND AGAIN
THIS IS THE ADDRESS OF FIRST UP
ON WILL WILL -- HOPEFULLY PHONE
INCLUDING -- YOU ALL OF YOUR
MANY OF YOU.
INTO.
A DISCUSSION AND I SEE -- OF US
MEMBER THIS AREA.
HAS THE COMMON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THOUGHT
YOUR STAFF MAY HAVE SEEN ME
EARLIER BUT I GUESS THEY DIDN'T --
MISTER BRADFORD IT'S NICE TO
HAVE YOU BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY --
THANK YOU GOT TO MODI I LIKE
PLEASE AS WELL.
THE SKINNER.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY -- BUT I GUESS THE ONLY
COMMENT THAT I WANTED TO LEAVE
WITH WAS THAT I JUST FIND IT
TROUBLING THAT WE'RE INSTEAD OF
CREATING ENVIRONMENTS WHERE.
WE PROMOTE EDUCATION AND WE
ALLOW STUDENTS TO HAVE THE
BENEFIT OF A VERY -- OF A
NURTURING ENVIRONMENT FOR
EDUCATION WE'RE ALL THE MORE --
GIVING INTO THE CULTURE OF HOW
WE MONETIZE EVERYTHING -- I
DON'T THINK THIS BILL HURTS THAT
THE CULTURE IS ALREADY THERE.
I THINK WE'RE ONLY.
ALLOWING FOR THERE TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE FREEDOM THROUGH
THIS BILL SO THAT MAYBE THIS TO
SOME EXTENT DOESN'T BECOME AN
ISSUE -- BUT I I I YOU KNOW THIS
IS THIS IS.
MARKET PRESSURES VERSUS CULTURE
VERSES HOW DO YOU CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU CAN
ACTUALLY ALLOW STUDENTS TO
THRIVE -- AND UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK IN THE LONG RUN.
ABOVE AND BEYOND EVERYTHING ELSE
I THINK WE'RE LOSING.
AND BUT WITH THAT I'D BE.
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE I'D
WANT THERE TO AT LEAST I'M
HOPING THAT.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR THERE TO BE
CERTAIN FREEDOMS OR CERTAIN
PRESSURES ALLEVIATED -- AND AND
SEE WHERE IT GOES IT'S IT'S KIND
OF AN EXPLORATORY OPPORTUNITY.
SO THANK YOU.
RICHARD RESEARCHER. FOR IT I I
ANSWER SKINNER -- CLOSED DOOR
HER COMMENTS WORSE SHOULD SERVE
AS OUR COLD BUT I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT AND I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE WITNESSES BOTH.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
IN OPPOSITION FOR YOUR INSIDE
AND AND YOUR THOUGHTS ASH AS
RELATES TO THIS BUT I THINK.
A CEMENT MISSOURIAN HIT THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD.
THIS IS ALREADY OUT OF CONTROL
THE HORSE IS ALREADY OUT THE BAR
WHEN YOU HAVE.
COLLEGE COACHES MAKE HIM AKING
MORE THAN.
PRESIDENTS OF UNIVERSITIES.
WHEN THEY MAKE MORE THAN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES?
WHO MAKE MORE THAN HEADS OF SOME
CORPORATIONS THIS IS ABOUT MONEY
FOLKS?
AND THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE NINE
YOUNG FOLKS IN EDUCATION AND
THAT THIS HOPEFULLY INCENTIVIZE
EASY JUNKETS TO STAY IN COLLEGE
BECAUSE WE'VE GIVEN THE EXAMPLES
OF A ONE AND DONE.
WHO GO TO COLLEGE JUST LONG
ENOUGH TO GETTHEIR NAME OUT
THERE TO BE DRAFTED AND THEY GO
ON TO MAKE MONEY BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEIR SHELF LIFE AS THE
ATHLETE?
IS LIMITED.
THIS IS ABOUT FAIRNESS FOR YOUNG
LADIES AS WELL.
OUR WE WANT BALLOTS WE'VE
DISCUSSED IN THIS LEGISLATURE
ABOUT GENDER EQUITY GENDER PAY
EQUITY FOR YEARS SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE WE'VE TALKED ALL LAST WEEK
DURING OUT THE WORLD CUP SOCCER
GAMES.
HOW APPALLED WE ALL WERE ALL
THAT THESE WOMEN ATHLETES MAKE
PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED
TO MEN?
AND FOR MOST ELITE ATHLETES WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF FOOTBALL MOST
OF THEM IF YOU'RE A LEAGUE
BASKETBALL PLAYER.
LIKE LEBRON JAMES YOU BYPASS
COLLEGE ALTOGETHER.
YOU KNOW YOU ARE YOU SAY AND
MOST MANY OF THESE GUYS NOW DO
ONE YEAR IF YOU'RE GOOD BASEBALL
PLAYER YOU'RE DRAFTED.
I'M USUALLY IN YOUR SENIOR YEAR
BY IT HI MAJOR LEAGUE TEAM.
END OF YOUR GREAT SOCCER PLAYER.
LIKE OUR FREDDIE A DO THIS KID
WAS RECRUITED AND DROPPED IT
FOURTEEN BY A PROFESSIONAL
SOCCER TEAM SO AGAIN WE HAVE
BEEN EXPLOITING THESE YOUNG
FOLKS.
MANY OF THEM WERE BLACK AND
BROWN FOR THE MOST PART MANY
COME FROM SOCIAL ECONOMIC --
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THIS IS ALL WE'RE SEEING IS THAT
WHILE THEY HAVE A I A A WORK
VALUE WE'RE NOT SEEN PAY THESE
ATHLETES WERE SEEN.
ALLOW THEM TO OUR CREW BE IT IN
SOME TRUST FUND OR SOME AND
NOBODY THAT THEY CAN SHARE AND
AFTER THEIR PLANE DAYS ARE OVER
THIS IS NOT ABOUT.
PAIN ATHLETES IT'S AGAIN IT'S
BOB BALANCING THE PLAYING FIELD.
AND GIVING EVERYBODY OPPORTUNITY
IN ITS INCENTIVE TO STAY IN
SCHOOL.
IT IS THE SENATE TO STAY IN
SCHOOL BECAUSE IF IF IF IF THEY
WERE ABLE TO EARN INCOME. FOR
LEASE PUT SOMETHING ASIDE MANY
THESE KIDS WOULD NOT BE DOING
ONE AND DONES THEY WOULD NOT BE
LEAVING COLLEGE AFTER JUST.
ONE SEASON THEY WOULD STAY FOR
ALL FOUR YEARS THEY WOULD GET
THEIR COLLEGE DEGREES SO I THINK
THIS IS.
A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF TODAY
ASH I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATORS SKINNER
I CLOSED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THAT WAS A COOK YOUR
CLOTHES.
ALL RIGHT GREAT SO MILLION WENT
UNSERVED HER PLEASE CALL.
SB TELL SIX SKINNER T. PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN
CHU EYEING TEAM.
DAVID CHIU DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
AND CHOI NOT VOTING FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
IN ORDER THAT I MISS AREA
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN HI.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
DID WITH THE THE RESORT WILL RUN
FOR HER SON WHO WAS JUST FOR TEN
IS THAT IT